[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five it is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it so jump in here we'll hang out
together and uh solve all of life's
problems you can call and ask our
opinion we are an expert on our opinion
we know what's happening with that so
jump in here let's talk triple eight
eight two five five two two five Melissa
is going to start this hour in
Indianapolis hi Melissa welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave I'm really excited to talk to
you guys hi Jade how are you
good thank you
so my husband and I have five kids and
we're on baby step seven
and uh yeah um but I share my four
oldest kids with an ex-husband and we
have a current court order that says we
would each claim two kids on our taxes
and but my ex's income has gone up
significantly over the past several
years and continues to go up and I found
out recently that he's being he told me
he was being phased out of the child tax
credit and probably won't benefit from
actually claiming the kids in the next
couple of years and so I was wondering
if it would be worth a hassle for me to
you know pursue getting permission from
the court and all of that for me to
claim all the kids myself or if I should
just let that go well I mean it's worth
some money
the question is how much they're gonna
cost a fool with it if your attorney if
you guys can order uh can agree to this
both of you sign off on it your attorney
could just file with a court and agreed
order
right so I should not be complicated it
shouldn't the reason that I even you
know had mention of it and and knew
about it was because I received this
email from my ex who said hey you know I
just thought I might you know reach out
to you and see maybe in 2023 you know
you could claim all because I'll just
let you claim all the kids and in
exchange then you know whatever the
child tax credit is for that year for
those two kids that you'd be claiming of
mine then we would decrease the child
support by the same amount why would you
bother
exactly you can stay home and break even
right I mean I I I don't get how this is
helpful
it's just a favor to him at that point I
mean it's okay if you want to do him a
favor
yeah it helps him but it helps you zero
okay well that's kind of what I figure
and it doesn't
oh you follow me
yeah you're going to get the you're
going to get the credit but he's going
to reduce it by that amount so you're
going to end up with exactly the same
amount of money When the Smoke Clears
and he's going to end up with more money
yeah and it doesn't necessarily help the
kids or no it doesn't affect the kids at
all
I'm guessing this is a pattern he has
lived his life by I win you lose
for sure which is why I saw the email
and thought well he's definitely not
going to be helping me out so that's
very suspicious like what do you really
want what are you trying what do you get
out of this what does he really want he
wants money this improves his financials
it's not being phased out so therefore
you know I thought this would be more
fair and then you know I would get the I
would get to keep the the state I mean
you can run the numbers on it and figure
out how many dollars it actually amounts
to in Euros life uh and you could offer
to split it with him instead of him
being the only one benefiting if it's
even worth it if that even pays the
court costs to file the agreed order
right the other thing I thought it was I
could offer to like to go ahead and file
all of them for me and claim them but
then put whatever extra money I get into
like toward College costs or something
because our oldest is now 15. she's a
sophomore well that would be a fair
offer but either way you need to benefit
enough that it
that you net net net if you have to put
it all into college and it reduces what
he has to put into college then no
you're just paying his bill for him
right and you're doing his work for him
again carrying his water for him again
so no I mean he needs to benefit half of
this you need to benefit half of it and
it needs to be worth it to file the
order
the actual savings it may not be worth
it when you add it all up and then look
at the legal cost it's probably just
don't screw with it it's my guess but it
might be enough I forget what is the
child tax credit did you look it up I
don't even know two thousand per kid
yeah which is why he was four thousand
dollars tax savings yeah so if you got
two thousand dollars he got two thousand
dollars cost you 500 to do the order
then that's fair you get nothing he gets
four thousand dollars no thank you
well the first way you said it it
sounded like a good idea but then when
you added in the part that he was going
to reduce you know right that then I
said I don't know yeah then we just go
yeah there's a pattern here I mean it's
okay but uh if you just want to do him a
favor but um but that's it I
yeah all right
usually in these situations there's more
to the story
as Paul Harvey used to say the rest of
the story all right Charlene's in
Charleston South Carolina hey Charlene
what's up
hi there thank you sorry for taking my
call sure how can we help
um yes I'm wondering I am in you know
close to 250 000 of medical school
education debt and I also have a auto
loan I paid off all my credit cards I'm
on baby steps too so I'm working on you
know paying off my debt I have a
thousand dollars in savings I'm sticking
to my budget but my question is I'm just
worried about not investing and not
standing because
um you know paying off my school loans
is going to take me several years
probably so I'm just like is it really
smart to only have a thousand dollars in
my savings if an emergency happens I
don't know if that's going to be enough
if I don't have a credit card how old
are you
I'm 34.
how long if you get crazy because you're
on baby step two how long is it going to
take you to pay off 250 000 of student
loans
I calculated it and if I'm like really
good and stick to my budget I can
probably do it in five years five years
what is your income
195 000. you're a whistle are you single
you're a Wilson I am I'm a single of no
children and I don't own a home you can
only pay off fifty thousand dollars out
of a 200 000 income yeah I'm with Dave
wimpy
you got to cut it down you're killing me
I can live I can only live on 150 000.
you're killing me look now now is the
time to get this done you're unattached
you don't have kids there is no reason
in the world that you can't get
scorched Earth on this
two years
one you get to do this in two years you
get to do this in two years I think you
need to flip it right now you're only
paying off 50 000 a year at that rate
you need to be living on 50 000 a year
and put the rest towards this two years
oh gosh yeah but no life no life you
gave up your life when you went to med
school
here's the thing if you keep making love
to travel yeah I know if you can't make
a lot of stuff with my friends if you
keep making excuses why you can't do
more do you want to know what you're
going to look up in five years and
you're still going to have this debt
it's got to be more painful for you to
stay like this than it is for you to
change you're a doc
right are you an MD
yeah I am okay what's your you have a
specialization
yeah I'm a pediatrician oh okay all
right cool
all right good well your income's not
going to go shooting through the roof
then but you're probably going to you're
probably going to see some increases and
Charlene you are a person who knows how
to delay pleasure for a win we know that
about you because you actually went all
the way through med school that's the
laying pleasure for a win now you get to
do it again
delay pleasure for a win
to go to live on nothing and clean this
the faster you clean this up the Richer
you're going to be
the faster you clean this up the less
stress you're going to have
the more you're going to like the person
in the mirror I would cut it to nothing
no nothing no eating out no travel no
nothing get out of debt that's what I
would do
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
's faction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
foreign
[Music]
hey if you're a new listener and you
want to dive deeper into this Ramsay
baby steps all this behind the scenes
Talk That snowballs all these things we
talk about click on get started at
ramseysolutions.com completely free
we'll help you figure out the best next
step for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today
ramseysolutions.com click get started
our question of the day comes from Jacob
and the Ramsey Baby Steps millionaires
group on Facebook
having 20 down what other tips would you
recommend for a first-time homebuyer
also is there anything that I need to
look out for
um yeah I would say there's a couple of
things to keep in mind I think it's
great that you're putting 20 percent
down uh we would say to do a deal where
your payment is no more than 25 percent
of your take home and that's taxes
Insurance all included in a conventional
loan and I love that you're putting 20
down because then you can avoid PMI
which is private mortgage insurance and
it's just an additional cost there but
with 20 down you can avoid that but I
feel like you're in pretty good shape I
mean other than that it sounds sounds
pretty good to me yeah a couple of
things good idea good question by the
way 15-year fixed rate 25 of your
take-home pay
um always
everyone
anytime you buy a piece of real estate
get Title Insurance a hundred percent of
the time
anytime you're buying a piece of
property that is not a traditional
subdivision lot
meaning it's very very predictable
always get a survey
so if you you know about three acres it
turned out to be 1.75 no that yeah no we
uh we you get a survey on it okay now
you got a standard subdivision lot that
is pre-platted and has changed hands
three or four times you don't have to
worry about that it is what it is but uh
if you're buying something otherwise get
a survey get title insurance and get a
home inspection
get a home inspection you're 20 years
old you're not an expert on much of
anything in that house uh unless you're
just I happen to be an electrician or
something then you would be right but
um yeah get it get a home inspection
period
um I've bought the sold several thousand
pieces of real estate I get a home
inspection last house I bought I got one
okay
um I can go in there and scratch around
in the crawl space and try to figure it
out but for what it costs to let
somebody else do it right
um
that's the thing uh don't buy a house
that is a great price but is ugly
from the street
first house I bought was that I got a
great deal and this house was
ugly from the street
there's no fixing ugly yeah you can't
fix ugly okay it's just still gonna be
no well we could we could no don't don't
don't don't try to fix ugly ugly you
just look like you you know oh I had
plastic surgery and you shouldn't have
bothered oh don't do it you know I mean
I mean don't you just can't fix it leave
it alone just don't don't it's not a
good buy because if you get a good buy
on it now when you get ready to sell it
you know what you have an ugly house
and you're gonna give somebody else a
good deal because nobody wants an ugly
house so that there's a reason it was
cheap when you bought it and there'll be
a reason it's cheap when you sell it so
good and that's also true with the
actual floor plan
I bought a house one time no actually I
didn't buy I rented it one time that was
a four bedroom but to get to one of the
bedrooms you had to walk through the
other bedroom oh yeah that's terrible
we used to call these country built
houses where you just keep adding on
adding all that rambling on and and you
just go yeah well there there was
actually no plan from the beginning yeah
and then you've got no plan so be
careful with that kind of stuff you can
you can get excited particularly on your
first buy and uh try to buy something
that's a little bit boring
that's good advice you know don't try to
like reinvent the world I'm gonna do a
rehab oh God no well I mean you could
pick you could pick something that's got
things that you can fix like if the
carpet's super ugly there's things that
are outdated like you can you can change
that but you can put you can put the
gutters up that's fine but don't tell me
you got to change though no yeah I gotta
tear out I gotta add no no no no no no
no just you just boring means less risk
going in and less risk going out and so
a nice little house with a little picket
fence and little bushes out front and it
looks you look at it from the street and
everybody goes oh that's cute that's
that's where you want to start what do
you think about Corner Lots because when
we bought in our neighborhood before we
came here we thought we had a good luck
because we were on the corner by the
gate and for us it was great we thought
oh we could take the dog out it's easy
access but then when we got ready to
sell
are a mixed blessing because generally
Corner Lots present well from the street
right but you have no freaking backyard
you got this little triangle back
there where they crammed the house back
inside at a 45 and so it depends on the
subdivision depends on the lot size
right all those kinds of things but
generally speaking you get a nice
presentation from the front and then
you're pinched in the back yeah that's
generally what you'll get so watch for
that that's not the end of the world but
watch for that again if you've got a
concern when you're looking at it know
that they're the buyer when you get
ready to sell it's going to have the
same concern so just don't right don't
get so excited you rationalize your way
into stupidity I know a guy who's done
that a lot in his life and um that's how
he has a radio show so be careful the
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jason is up next
in Detroit hey Jason welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey guys thank you so much for the call
I appreciate it sure
um Dave
um uh you you've you and God have
changed my life so I uh appreciate all
that you've done over the years
um pretty fortunate to live um
completely debt-free including my house
um at 48 years old way to go and
um thanks thanks my my wife and I have
worked pretty hard to uh kind of get
there financially
um I've actually been in a full-time
Ministry most of my adult life
um and uh currently I am part-time uh on
staff in a church and then part-time I
operate a food pantry and
um I absolutely love my work I I love
what I do
um the issue that I I struggle with a
little bit is I I hardly make any money
um being into non-profit situations
um my wife's a school teacher and has
been for 20 plus years so she's kind of
at the top of the income scale we're
doing all the things we have zero debt
we're you know she has the pension and
then we've got
um some other uh Investments and that
that sort of thing but my question is
you know I literally I mean with what I
do I I take home a couple thousand bucks
a month at this stage in the game and
I'm about 30 years into my career and I
guess I'm just trying to decide
um is that okay for me
um you know is it I don't
well I guess that's what you're calling
about it so you don't think it is
well I'm just I guess I just need some
perspective I I'm I love what I do and I
I I you know I get to help people every
day and
um it's extremely rewarding work and I
can see myself doing it until I die I
don't you know I want to die with my
boots on but
um without any debt and you know still
being able to set aside you know funds
for the future
um I guess
um I would love to make more money but I
just don't know if I'm ever going to
find that in kind of the non-profit
World
um so I guess I just was hoping for a
little insight on that
well you're obviously a good man you're
obviously a guy who loves to help people
you're pastoring you run a food pantry
you got a big old heart
and there's no question about that
um
80 of Pastors in North America are by
vocational
they have a day job
that's wild number
um and did you start this food pantry
start it however I took it over and had
to completely revamp it uh it's kind of
yours yeah I thought so I kind of
smelled that the way you're talking
about it you know there's nothing wrong
spiritually morally ethically with what
you're doing nothing wrong with it at
all there's also nothing wrong with
exploring some other avenues that you
could utilize that wonderful large heart
of yours to help people and in the
process of serving them you made more
money there's nothing wrong with that
either that's the seat I sit in
so I mean there's lots of ways you can
help people and love people well and
they love paying you for it by the way
so maybe a counseling Ministry maybe
some other things you can add on I don't
know what it is but I would look towards
that kind of a thing
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Annie is next in
Nashville hi Annie welcome to the Ramsay
show
Hi how are you guys doing today better
than we deserve how can we help
so my husband and I our first time home
buyers we just started the process and
I've been talking to a local mortgage
broker and he gave us some information
on 30-year versus 15-year mortgages we
want to do the 15-year we're trying to
follow the plan we have a sizable down
payment
but he did say which I thought this was
kind of strange I just don't understand
this that if we want the 15-year we are
required to do a rate buy down to get
like a little lower interest rate so I
just didn't know what that was I never
heard of that before he said it would be
about a point or point and a half to get
the rate buy down
hahaha
uh uh uh you need to call Churchill
Mortgage
and get with a new mortgage broker okay
there are two things you can do to buy
down rates uh I
think I'm hearing
that he just wants you to pay points
that is not a true buy down that's just
Points each point is one percent of the
loan amount
and will reduce your interest rate by
about an eighth between an eighth and a
quarter somewhere in there but usually
around an eighth of a percent which
means it takes you eight years to recoup
that no thank you I'll pass
so paying points is not a good thing and
I'm pretty sure by the way that
increases what goes in his pocket at the
closing that's why I'm um rolling my
eyes a bit here I don't know if you can
hear it over the radio but I was and so
um the an actual buy down is a like a
three two one buy down and it would be a
three percent reduction the first year
or a two one buy down two percent
reduction the first year one percent
reduction the second year and then it
goes on up to the regular rate and all
that is is you're just giving yourself
some money up front to subsidize
yourself
now if the seller pays your two one buy
down like in the old days when things
were a little calmer than they are right
now a builder might pay for a 2-1 buy
down
okay in other words they would pay two
percent pay the you know just at .02
right what it's going to cost you to
reduce the rate by two percent and then
point one so it's going to cost them
three percent out of pocket to do a 2-1
buy down or six percent out of pocket to
do a three two one buy down if the
seller pays that that's free money you
got a deal okay but if you're if you're
gonna pay for your own buy down uh
that's uh not as bad as points but it's
there's no reason to do it
okay does that make sense you understand
the difference in what I'm saying points
are prepaid interest both of these are
prepaid interest points are a form of
prepaid interest and one point will
reduce the roughly an eighth of a
percent APR for the life of the loan a
true buy down is just it's a two one buy
down each you take your current rate
let's call it six percent it'd be four
percent the first year five percent the
second year and six percent from then on
and you pay that difference up front at
the closing
which you could have just done that for
yourself if you're just swapping pockets
so actually let me think about this
Cindy if the seller's not paying it
we're going to do neither of these
that's the moral of the story
okay is the seller paying it
he acted like I was to get the 15-year
this is something I would have to do why
do a race 15 years generally cheaper
than a 30 year
anyway and are they saying you can't
qualify
so he said he said that the 30-year
would be
[Music]
and if I 15 year would be the same
unless I did this rate buy down then I
could get like 6.5 or something
new mortgage broker new one okay he just
lost the business yeah because 15-year
quoted at what we call a par quote 0.0
origination is always cheaper than a
30-year
okay and for you you know he's monkeying
with you to put his line in his pocket
so it's that's what I think I'm not a
hundred percent sure but having done
about a bazillion of these I'm pretty
sure yeah I I go to Churchill talk to
them and see if they give you the exact
same thing if they do I'll shut up and
say that I was wrong about the guy's
character but
when is it better to just make a larger
down payment as opposed to attempting a
three two one the larger down payment uh
doesn't reduce well it would reduce the
payment but it doesn't reduce it as much
mathematically
um so actually it would be no it
wouldn't it wouldn't because I guess
what I'm saying is there is there math
that you need to do to find out what
that point would be no it's it's don't
subsidize your own loan
is the moral of the story both of them
are a form of subsidizing your own
interest rate prepaying it by prepaying
it in their different forms points or
buy Downs so if the seller is paying
points or the seller is paying a buy
down that's different right and all
things being equal meaning no points no
origination which is called a par quote
your 30 should match your your 15 should
be a little bit less a it should be a
quarter of a point half a point less on
your APR generally speaking it is now
there might be a glitch in the
environment at this moment in the bond
market that's doing that I I'm not 100
sure but most of the time throughout
30 almost 40 years of being in the real
estate and around real estate business
that's what my experience has been so
but double check you need to get another
quote I I'm I just smell
um I I don't it doesn't it doesn't smell
right that's all right dude just leave
it at that all right Jake is in
Milwaukee hi Jake how are you
hi Dave hi Jade hi um I'm
okay I'm on baby step two
um and I'm kind of in a little
situation where I don't know how much I
owe I
my father passed in 2016.
and he didn't have a will the only thing
he ever did he told me is that he was
gonna set me as a beneficiary and if
anything happened that you know I would
have to take care of it for
for my sister for myself and my sister
um and I mean so he's only ever told me
that verbally and well when he passed we
got two hundred thousand
um
in a policy and
it's coming up I've been paying my
sister monthly so she can go and finish
school debt free which she has now
graduated
um and so there's about five thousand
left on just the half so 95 000 paid
and
I kind of don't know
how much more I owe her because all the
things I've done with the with the money
have been kind of commingled with my own
finances
Well you certainly are the five thousand
right because that total is one hundred
thousand yeah no no doubt okay then have
you invested the money during this time
I I did I invested
um in 100 000 of it in real estate okay
that would be your hundred thousand
and then I invested others at parts and
stock
well okay and well I would have been I
would have done better with your four
fund portfolio but I I've actually lost
money on the part I invested in stock
because
I mean I and I don't know what you owe
or you don't know or anything legally
morally you told too bad she would get
half the money so we know she's getting
the 5 000 even if you screwed around
lost some of her half
then you would still cover that five
thousand morally if you're doing what
your dad asks you to do right
yeah so how much money have you made on
the real estate
um on paper I mean before you know
selling fees and all that it's probably
like 75 000. okay
what do you make a year
uh actually I I'd make about that 75.
what do you think the right thing to do
is
[Music]
hello I I mean probably just
probably just cut that in half and then
say and get and convert half of that but
I think you invested your half into real
estate personally
um I and I think you lost some of her
house so I think you covered the five
and if you want to throw another 10 on
there for fun to make you feel better
that's fine but I don't think you owe
her anything much more than that and I'm
certainly not going to have to sell the
real estate to get her half out of that
that's so convoluted Wicked no thank you
[Music]
foreign thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America our 2023 live event schedule is
jam-packed and sold out Coast to Coast
baby hey man we've had a blast we were
just in Indianapolis and then over in
Austin Texas April 24th will be in Salt
Lake City Utah with Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Christina Ellis and me May 2nd
will be Jade Washoe no that's Christine
Ellis you were you did the first two
that's right okay uh May 2nd Anaheim
California Dr John deloney Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis and me and smart
conference is back and we're going to
kick it off kick it up a notch with a
full weekend here at Nashville this will
be the inaugural event at the uh Ramsey
Event Center where they're putting in
the final touches up there today putting
bushes down and rolling out the sod and
which is kind of like rolling out gold
and uh yeah it's gonna be awesome and we
have the money in marriage uh by the way
that's April 14th and 15th there's a few
tickets left uh ramsaysolutions.com
events for all of these Salt Lake City
Anaheim Nashville for smart conference
here on our campus the money and
marriage getaway a chance for you and
your spouse to disconnect from everyday
life spend a few days focusing on your
marriage that'll be here in Nashville
October 19-21 Dr John deloney and Rachel
Cruz make your plans to get to all of
these don't miss any of them
ramsesolutions.com
events uh
note to
everyone that is over 18 and breathing
do not leave verbal instructions
to
your
heirs ah
do a will
it's the responsible adult thing to do
do a will go to Mama bearlegalforms.com
get you a will state specific do oh well
if you have moved States you need a new
will because state law handles your
estate so you need to do away if you
hate your relatives leave a larger state
with mixed instructions verbally to all
of them they will spend the next 25
years of their life fighting
this is how you can screw up a family oh
yeah you can screw up and leave your son
feeling guilty for not having properly
taken care of his little sister because
he didn't have good instructions just
split it with her I'm not going to do a
wheel
oh you're killing me and can I take it a
step further can you talk to your family
members about the will hello do a
reading of the will do a review if
you're going to piss someone off do it
while you're live please
you're doing cocaine Junior you're out
of the will go ahead and tell them that
maybe they'll get off the cocaine who
knew you know we don't we do not leave
inheritance to heroin addicts and so I'm
sorry I'm sorry Susie you're not in the
will but Dave there's can I just say as
as this generation talking to my parents
and our generation of people talking to
our parents they don't want to talk to
us about money I know we can we can ask
hey Mom Dad you know I'm trying to plan
I want to know about long-term care I
want to know about your will I want to
know and they don't want to tell us
what's going on I know
and I'm yelling at them right now yeah
let them know
uh you're talking to my generation I
guess hey my generation you're being
stupid do a will do a will do a will do
a will do a will do a will do a will do
a will do a will I don't care what you
do with your money it's your money but
do it on purpose live an act of
diligence and act of intentionality keep
the government's hands off of it it gets
so convoluted and screwed up the lawyers
end up with everything and people end up
pissed off for decades over a piece of
furniture
I said you were going to leave that to
her
oh gee yep uh it's a piece of come on
leave it to a will do we'll do it we'll
do we'll do we'll do it it's easy and my
wife actually cornered me on this the
other day because I've got a very
detailed estate plan we have the
uh update on the estate plan every year
I'm meeting with my whole family and my
leadership team here at Ramsey and this
is what happens if Dave dies this year I
call it the Monty Python move meeting
I'm feeling much better it's just a
flesh wound yeah so um but it's uh it's
awkward as crud to do this
I'm here I'm okay I'm right here in the
corner no this is what happens if Dave
dies this year right so uh but I hadn't
done it like I have an antique water ski
collection
I have interesting I have a gun
collection okay too many cars and
Sharon's the other day goes what do you
want me to do with all that crap and I'm
like I don't know do whatever you want
to with it she goes Dave Ramsey says
have a plan
it's not in you don't have it so you
have to write up a document not to do
the oil but just say here's what you do
with the water skis is what you do cars
and here's what you do with the guns and
um here here's where you call and uh
which of our kids can help you with that
process and
because she wouldn't even yeah oh my
gosh look I'm not mad at that I feel
like that that's a good call a good call
I mean she called me out on my own stuff
so there you go do a will do a will all
right Kareem is with us in Tampa hi
Kareem welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi your wife sounds like a very smart
woman yeah
we know we've known that for a very long
time and I'm only and yet I'm the one
doing the show so how can I help
well I'm really looking forward to
listening to your great advice but right
a little bit first I just wanted to
mention my big brother Gill because he's
the one that turned me on to listening
to your podcast and he followed your
plan and to become debt free and he is
on his way to becoming a millionaire Wow
way to go way to go girls he's listening
so I'm sure he's excited yeah oh
all right so my question this is this is
the good stuff all right so we have an
investment property okay it's a condo we
owe about 250 000 on the condo and it's
worth about 1.3 million oh wow I hate it
when I know it was wonderful you know
Tampa is booming right now so I'm really
lucky to have come in right before right
and the idea is this
um we bought the condo at 350. so our
capital gains is going to be extremely
high it's going to be in the millions no
and we don't know what to do because in
a year and a half our five-year arm ends
and we're gonna have to renegotiate our
interest rate and right now our interest
rate is three percent and we are
terrified to find out what the interest
rate's going to be
so we don't know what to do with this do
we do a 1031 uh we also owe about 900
000 on our current home and our home
rate right now is at 2.65 percent
so what do we do what do we do there's
so many options what's the best option
well you've done very well on it
congratulations
that's fabulous if you do sell it your
capital gains rate will be 15 unless
you're making over 450 000 household
income are you yeah it's going to spend
20. yeah 20
um probably over a million dollars so
it's gonna be 200 250
000 somewhere in there right that's your
taxes to sell it if you do that you pay
off your house that's one option right
you won't quite have enough to pay off
your house but you probably have some
other money
um that'd be a cool option obviously a
1031 defers those gains it's a trading
for another property if your only reason
for doing that is to avoid the fear of
the mortgage how much money do you have
um in terms of cash flow or let me ask
two questions how much cash do you have
not counting retirement cash and
Investments non-retirement
okay so we have I would say total total
about two hundred thousand okay and
what's your household income
uh about five hundred thousand okay so
if you want to keep this
just pay it off
I should just pay off the condo yeah and
then you don't have to worry about the
five because I'm worried about the five
years it's kind of funny because you
make 500 000 a year and you only have a
250 000 mortgage no I'm not worried I
mean it's not there's nothing you said
you were you said you were I'm freaked
about the interest rates I got a call
coming you have a five-year call right I
mean you have five years to make the
decision so sometime in the next five
years preferably the next eighteen no
one year I have one year one year oh I'm
misunderstood I did too I thought you
said it
our five-year arm is ending in a year oh
is it going to adjust or is it going is
it a call
it's gonna adjust right I think it's
gonna be yeah it's going to be adjusting
oh it's just an adjustment so that's not
the other one but I would pay it off I
don't know I would try to pay it off and
keep it if you like it if you like the
property the cleanest things just pay it
off and keep it I wouldn't be motivated
to sell it by the mortgage not with your
income and your cash and I think you
like it it sounds like she does they
like the area I kind of like it it's
done well for them it's been sweet but
it's just up to you I mean if you're
gonna keep it if you want to if the only
thing driving this is the mortgage just
pay the mortgage off in the next year
you can do that this is the Ramsey Show
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Anna is with us in San Francisco hey
Anna how are you
I'm good thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so I recently went on a game show
and I had the opportunity to play for my
dream car I got so close but I lost
and it's just killing me I'm so sad
about losing and not getting this car
and my husband and I talked it over and
um we want to know a can we maybe afford
to buy this card
and B if we can is it a wise thing for
us to do because sometimes dream cars
are just dream cars right
I I am so I'm trying to recover from all
of this in the moment
um what is the car and how much does it
cost you know the answer to all of this
by the way I'm BMW X3 and it's 50 000 on
the money how much money do you make
your personal income oh well to get
combined because I don't work right now
is about 175 a year okay and the car is
fifty thousand
yes what is it brand new
it's a BMW X3 oh you said that okay all
right so do you currently have debt
no debt no debt do you currently have
savings
we have just over 100 Grand in savings
yes and what do you drive right now
a minivan what does he drive
we just have the minivan that's it we
have one card of your name
um we have one card to our name we
like uh what do you call it like a Honda
CRV we're borrowing it on and off if we
occasionally need a second car from my
mother-in-law I'm assuming you're not to
a million dollar net worth yet or am I
wrong
um actually we are we are because of our
house okay we have some 401k
is now here's here's our rule of thumb
we would normally say that if you're a
millionaire
you could purchase a brand new vehicle
but we also say that we don't want more
than you know you don't want more than
50 of your annual income tied up in
vehicles so that's why I was asking what
else you have you checked both boxes oh
and you got to pay cash you checked all
three boxes
when did you uh when was the game show
episode when were you on it
about a month ago
and you've got the 50. you've got the 50
000 to pay cash for it right
we do but then it just drops our savings
to about 50 degrees yeah I got that I
but which is still 50 Grand is still
three to six months expenses for you
right mm-hmm
yeah
definitely so just walk me through I'll
be honest with you starting out this
call I was like this call is crazy but
you do check all the boxes but you still
sound like uh I don't know like at first
you sounded really excited about it and
now it's almost like as I walked you
through it you you're feeling more
sobered about it and now you're feeling
like you don't want to so explain that
to me
well so before I went on the show we had
sat in this car we had driven this car
and we had said to ourselves hey if
someone gave us this car for free
absolutely we'll take it wise we weren't
sure if it was wise and so we walked
away from the lot several times not
buying this car but then I go on this
show and it's right there and I play all
these rounds and I'm like 50 50 away
from it and I lose it and I'm like oh
maybe I do really want this car well the
game show the game show aside I'm sorry
you lost but what game show was it can
you just say it
are you not allowed to this is Right
Price is Right I love it
um game show aside you'll I feel like
because it was offered to you for free
you were like yes I won and now that
it's not free anymore you're realizing
man fifty thousand dollars is a lot of
money here's the thing you can afford it
you get sounds like you guys have
sacrificed to win you've been driving an
old minivan
if you can afford it and here's the
thing if you can't afford that one what
if you got a year or two used
would that scratch the itch and and
still make you feel like you're being
responsible because here's the thing you
would be being responsible even if you
bought it outright
but right now it sounds like you're
dealing an emotion and it doesn't feel
responsible would it feel responsible if
you bought it two years used
I think that
thing better um
it feels kind of scary to do that yeah
you guys have done a great job with
money to get where you are
and so you have good instincts
and this is bothering you I used to have
a friend on investments he would say
when in doubt don't
and you have so much doubt around this I
don't think it's going to bring you as
much thrill as it is going to bring you
loss of Peace just you you're again
you're you've checked every box you're
not violating a single thing that we
teach by buying the car but you've got
to sleep right now you've got you this
is Bob now you got to pay cash for it
okay but uh but if you're not going to
if it's I'm I'm a little bit afraid just
listening to you that it's gonna take
more from you than it adds to you do you
know what I'm saying I just wanted card
for free that's what that's what it is
I'm not the host I can't help you with
that I'm on the Dave Ramsey show or the
Ramsey Show not the Price Is Right
otherwise I would just give you the car
but um yeah I get that though I would go
get I I think I'm with Jade because of
the hesitation not because of anything
else because it's bothering you I think
I would go buy a 30 000 version of this
X3 which is a great car by the way
they're very cool
um
drive that for a while if you guys
continue making 175 000 a year and you
continue saving money and you continue
you'll be able to drive anything you
want to drive
the truck I drove over here today I
would never have dreamed I would buy a
truck like that you know like 10 years
ago and now it's like oh yeah it's okay
you know but I I never drink even though
I had the money 10 years ago I would
never but emotionally you weren't ready
to buy it emotionally I'm in a different
place I had you know there was no angst
I went yeah sure Sharon you okay with
this yeah let's do it okay kind of a
five minute conversation I'm like oh I
love it order the dadgum thing you know
so but but the first time I moved up I
Remember The Angst yeah what she's
feeling I remember this sense of um am I
being dumb I don't want to be dumb
that's a good that's a good thing to
have those breaks on you way to go I
think that's part of honestly I think
that's part of this process when you
buckle down and you're saying no to
yourself a lot even if you're saying not
now when you finally get to the time
that it's now it feels weird
I think a lot of people struggle with
that actually spending their money yeah
oh they do it's uh it's hard and
you know if if you call me up and you
made
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
500 000 a union a five million dollar
net worth I will tell you to just go do
it now I would tell you go do it but
this is a it's 50 of your liquid savings
that does that kind of gives you a
little bit a moment there and you're
catching the throat and I think it
depends also how your net worth is
distributed if all of it's in the house
most of it is she said yeah so so yeah
that that's a good point too that's you
know so I you're okay to do it if you
want to do it but you don't feel good
about it that's what we're observing
yeah this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
question coming in about taxes oh we get
it taxes are confusing but to help you
get a better handle on them let's unpack
a question from one of our listeners can
you explain how capital gains tax works
yes there are two types of income tax
mainly in America uh a classic what we
call ordinary income which is your
income tax and then there's a gain on an
asset like a share of stock a piece of
real estate your gain is what it goes up
in value over what you paid for it with
a few adjustments but that's basically
it that is a capital gain your gang
you've gained capital on this so you buy
a piece of land for a hundred thousand
dollars and you sell it for a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars after
expenses you net fifty thousand dollars
that is your capital gain uh if you make
under four hundred fifty thousand
dollars married filing jointly your
capital gains tax rate is only 15
it's even less if you have a small
income and it's twenty percent if you
make over 450 but it's still less than
ordinary income uh well can be less than
ordinary income
so um generally is so uh if you it you
know
certain assets can be exempt from
capital gains taxes altogether for
instance your personal residence you can
make up to a half a million dollars
married filing jointly 250 is a single
uh on that if you've owned the property
for two years or longer you have zero
taxes on that
so I recently sold a home uh 18 months
ago and the half a million dollar gain
was tax free you don't have to buy
another house with it it's just free
you can buy another house with it but
you don't have to in the old days you
had to buy another house even on your
personal residence but that's all
changed now so for online software that
includes all major federal forms with
low upfront pricing and no hidden fees
check out Ramsey smart tax for
additional support if you've got a
complicated return check out Ramsey
trusted tax Pros like one of our
endorsed local providers go to
ramseysolutions.com tax and you can
learn more ramsesolutions.com tax all
right Connors in Cincinnati hey Connor
welcome to the Ramsay show
better than I deserve what's up
great yeah so my wife and I are recently
debt free outside of our mortgage good
and my question is yeah thank you my
question is regarding my company's
Employee Stock purchase plan and whether
whether it be wise to invest in that as
part of the 15 that goes into retirement
or possibly even like a shorter term
around seven to eight years
uh-huh
I wouldn't do it
I would invest the 15 into mutual funds
because single stock and your company
stock I don't know what company you work
for but it's more risk to put basically
all of your eggs in one basket as
opposed to spreading them around like
you would do in mutual funds
yeah if you're going to do if you're
going to buy a company stock or any
single stock I would only do it after
your home is paid for
and that would be maybe step seven
activity now let's say we're over there
and let's look at your situation okay by
law they are discounting the stock and
an employee purchase 15 correct
correct yeah and um so it let's say
you're putting 15 of your income into
retirement maybe step four you're taking
care of your kids college five you paid
off your house six so now we're sitting
at baby step seven do I want to play
with this stock since I'm getting a 15
discount you might you might you don't
want more than 10 percent of your net
worth total in single stocks because
single stocks are a lot more risk and to
prove that Connor here here's what would
be interesting I don't even know your
company name okay and I don't want to
know so all right in a minute we'll see
but right now I don't to make this
statement I don't need to know you know
your company name go back and look you
pull it up pull up your company stock on
the internet and look at a chart that
shows the 52-week high and 52-week low
you likely will see a swing greater than
15 between the two
in the last in the last year right now
I'm sorry
yeah it's a pretty large drop right now
in the last year yeah okay and so um
they sometimes they shoot up sometimes
they shoot down but even a very stable
name brand
uh company like a Home Depot that we all
know the name of or something it's not
unusual it would be unusual for it to
not vacillate as your possible high or
your possible low so my point being is
the 15 discount might just be enough to
cover your losses
that's a good point in the coming year
and so the volatility of the single
stock is represented there and tells you
why we don't play single stocks I don't
own any I don't own one
uh and so that that's you know Jade's
right I'm going to stay away from it
until you get to maybe step seven and
even then
don't think that the 15 is special it's
all Company stock is that way every
everybody that has a company stock
purchase plan it's 15 discount and uh
unless it's a small closely held company
and they've got a different thing but
I'm talking about publicly traded Big
Board uh New York you know New York
Stock Exchange type stocks that's what
it's going to be and you're probably
going to find your 52-week high and low
to be the distance between those two to
be greater than 15 percent yeah I
wouldn't do it yeah and then if you're
so you know it's just if you've got a
real itch there you want to scratch put
a little money in it after you're in
baby step seven but you're really not
it's not knocking it out of the park oh
I got a 15 discount I made money before
I started no that's my point you didn't
probably all right Ryan is with us in
Mayfield Kentucky Ryan what's up
hey now uh good afternoon Jane Dave
thanks for taking my call sure how can
we help
um so I have a question about
um about the budget uh I've changed well
it's been about two years now from
teaching I taught for nine years and got
a monthly check it was easy to figure
out monthly expenses and plan but now
I'm Farming and I get paid five times a
year
um it's regular it's kind of predictable
five times a year but I'm having trouble
it's about 70 days I think per paycheck
or something like that and I'm having
trouble planning when I write myself a
check now you know from the farm
what how to figure out what expenses to
cover do I do I kind of do a
a budget for every
what two and a half months or I'm trying
to figure out the logistically the best
way to plan for that yeah the first
thing is farming is a business and so
you're running a business as a separate
checking account
now once you've paid your expenses at
the business your net profit is what you
can take home
so when you get a crop that comes in you
got to clear your you got to clear your
stuff right and then what's left and
what you don't need to replant
and so on is what you can take home now
once you take that home then you say we
need X number of dollars five thousand
dollars a month seven thousand dollars a
month whatever it is to to exist and
then you just pay you know you just pay
yourself five thousand dollars a month
out of the business account okay well so
yeah so I have how much we need and what
our expenses are and we're good on as
far as it's about five times a year but
we do about maybe uh twelve thousand
dollars each time and we're good on the
farm and that pays our bills but it's
it's the planning ahead of time
for 70 days like using the app like the
logistics of saying
it's because we pay ourselves
keep the money yeah keep the money in
the business account
and pay yourself a monthly pay check
yeah just give yourself the five
thousand dollars once a month okay
okay yeah so instead of paying at the
end of the flock when the farm gets paid
just go ahead and divide that monthly
and pay myself 12 times a year instead
of a five times a year yeah that's what
I would do it's easier to keep up with
yeah that's probably because otherwise I
mean because you're controlling you're
controlling 100 of both accounts there's
no other players right
well I I do have a business partner uh
25 on the farm but I'm still controlling
I just cut him that disbursement then
you may want to just set us out a
separate personal account and chunk 70
days worth of
monthly rate in there let's let's just
call it 90 days worth put three months
in there yeah and then pay your and then
just divide it but you know take out a
third a third a third and then do it
again
yeah because looking at the monthly
bills it's like well okay we it's about
3 000 a month is kind of what we need
but it's like well if it's two and a
half months it's like do I write myself
you know nine thousand dollars you know
that's where I was having trouble with
the logistics on planning that like with
the budget yeah it helps to have a
separate account yeah I probably would
open a third account yeah I'd probably
open a third account separate from the
businesses effort from your checking and
say okay I'm gonna move this money
because it helps me to visually go all
right I just got paid for the month of
March I just got paid for the month of
April yeah and I'm taking it out of
there he doesn't need to move three
months of money into his personal
checking account and try to
keep from spending keep from spending it
for three months that's a terrible idea
that's a problem yeah good good question
man thank you for joining us this is the
Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions and by
the way you should be there's always a
50 to 200 folks hanging out with us
while we do the show uh it's on the
glass and free coffee and free homemade
cookies come by and see us when you're
in Nashville anyway on the debt free
stage Andrew is with us hey Andrew how
are you I am good I'm very excited to do
this screen with you well we're honored
to have you where do you live sir I live
in Milwaukee Milwaukee cool and how much
debt have you paid off 155
000 all right and how long did this take
you just about 24 months cool and uh
your range of income during that time
started off a little slow uh new grad
physical therapist right around the
start of covet at 39 000 but then at the
peak of my gazelle intensity I got it up
to 185 thousand dollars
wow wow PT yeah wow gracious so I'm
guessing 155 000 was PT student debt 100
oh man oh man what inspired you to do
this 20 four months ago how did you get
to do the Ramsay way yeah so it goes a
little further back than that sometime
in college I learned that I should be a
little better with my money and I knew
my older brother was doing better with
that at the time so I reached out to him
I'm like hey what can I be doing and he
said there's this guy he has these Steps
step one save a thousand dollars so I
turned around I did that and I went back
to my brother and I said all right done
with step two and he said you have to
pay off all of your debt and I was just
like well that just can't be right I
need to get this guy's name figure out
what he's really about period talk to
him he's wrong right that was the
exception so then I that's when I got
immersed in all of your teachings and
then um throughout the rest of my
schooling I applied everything that you
were suggesting to try and limit how
much more debt I was going into and then
once I graduated I was able to hit the
ground running once I got my big boy job
yeah how's it feel to be free it feels
amazing so suffering yeah I'm so proud
of you man thank you thank you so much
love you well done so now that you're
debt free
what are your big plans so
um yeah now that this part of my life is
over
um the next big thing I want to work on
is like building a family and I have a
Colleen here with me today and that
actually leads me into my next question
and I know I know Colleen likes
surprises so
um Colleen I love you so much and your
support in the last two and a half years
has meant so much to me and I really
want the next part of my life with you
to be
um
uh to start a family so
you did you marry me of course I
hope
[Applause]
that free screen clicked that close
pretty quick
trust me I know what it looks like she
said I picked it out oh you picked it
out yeah actually Dave I called you
about a year ago to the day to ask you
about how do I budget for this in the
middle of like my debt free journey and
I talked to you about a year ago um with
John deloney so this is a full circle oh
wow yeah so we helped pick out the ring
too basically yeah pretty much I love it
did you put it on did she put it on no
she didn't put it away
put it on put it on me oh is that how it
works oh yeah this is how this works
dude
how dare you
wow
I know the microphones are in the way of
the kiss okay I love it a debt-free
scream engagement all in one Fell Swoop
you're fairly efficient dude yeah thank
you
congratulations thank you so much so we
don't usually let uh the uh the extended
girlfriend be a part of the debt-free
scream she's he or she a boyfriend
girlfriend's off to the side cheering
you on until they're not but uh he asked
to do this and so that's why we got you
up on the stage so we're all in on this
we completely tricked you you can blame
us too
congratulations you too thank you so I'm
very very proud of you how long have you
all been dating about two and a half
years oh wow okay well it's time okay
come on man right yeah yeah you're
working on this you're you're been
working all the time though right yeah
so it's been tough but now we've got a
solid foundation to uh bring the family
on in that's exciting it sounds like how
did y'all meet uh we met on Bumble okay
yeah very good connection we were both
in school at the time and then yeah just
worked out after the first day I knew I
wanted to want her to be my girlfriend
last year the very next time I saw her
so wow yeah wow you had no idea this was
coming did you not today no I no I
didn't I can't believe it actually yeah
I did a pretty good job of just yeah
yeah you're pretty Cool Hand Luke up
here yeah you are people would have been
sweating into their socks I don't know
yeah
that's exciting exciting stuff so it
sounds like you kind of you knew this do
you guys have a a date in mind or is
this totally new we don't it's um we've
talked about it we've talked about
future plans but and we haven't an idea
of what we want to do as far as getting
married we want to kind of do our own
vacation sort of thing but as far as as
far as setting a date and all that
that's our drive out of here that's
going to be the fun conversation we look
forward to that's exciting I have a I
have a question to ask this is
controversial so are you on board with
all of this Colleen all this debt free
stuff too late now oh yeah I mean we
wouldn't I wouldn't be here if I were
not on board with it and I'm also debt
free and I also paid off my student
loans during our relationship together
and I probably wouldn't have if it
weren't for dating him and hearing a lot
of Dave Ramsey all the time this is how
it's done I like it I like it well done
you two how old are you gosh I just
turned 27 yesterday and I'm 28. all
right and so you're going to have a
wonderful household income north of 200
000. I don't even know what you make
Colleen but I'm pretty pretty sure
that's where you all will be and uh zero
student loan debt and wow what a great
way to start you guys got a great
launching pad I'm so proud of you
thank you and thank you for honoring us
and letting us be a little part of this
whole thing and letting you show off in
front of about 15 or 20 million people
yeah pretty cool not many people get
engaged in front of 15 million people
right it's not expecting that yeah
you guys did good yeah and they're not
even weird like on The Bachelor or
something these are like normal people
normal people yeah I love it you didn't
have to go get trapped in a house
somewhere or something to do it yeah
okay wow look at you guys very very cool
so proud of y'all way to go well I think
Colleen you paid off your student loans
too so I think we're debt free yeah is
appropriate for this for the debt free
scream what do you all think oh yeah for
sure Andrew and Colleen recently engaged
like three minutes ago uh I love it
congratulations you two from Milwaukee
Wisconsin he paid off 154 155 000 in 24
months and she paid off her student
loans while they were dating two and now
boy they got a bright future count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
wow well played dude well played
love it very cool I think that is the
third or fourth maybe fifth over the
years engagements on the air but it's
been a while I don't I think it's the
first one in this building I've never
seen one that is special yeah very cool
he got her too she had no idea oh yeah
no she had no idea well she said she
picked out the ring but that must have
been just well just a question what I
like yeah I like one like that yeah yeah
that kind of thing so yeah very very fun
I tell you what they had the right
conversations early on you can tell that
just shut up it's set up if you can be
in agreement on money in-laws religion
and kids before you're engaged and
married you you got a real shot at it
that's a big thing way to go you two
that's great very very cool they're fun
to watch too that's great so 27 years
old he made 39 up to 185. that right
there and so you can start putting some
numbers with that boys and girls I mean
I don't know I don't even know what she
does I didn't ask but but uh let's just
say she made 50 or 60 or 70 or whatever
then they're going to be up over 200 two
and a quarter two and a half something
like that at 27 years old a quarter
million dollar household income and no
payments of any kind nope
and be in a position to not only take
care of them their future children uh
change your family tree but also be in a
position to uh be outrageously
outlandishly generous in their community
and be a help uh rather than a hindrance
to those around them what a cool way to
start life that is it right there that's
that's what they did as a blueprint for
folks to follow they did they did that
right
man if I had only been so smart I know I
I'm looking back thinking well you start
out a half million I did at least we
paid cash for the wedding that's one
thing we did right hopefully they do as
well I'm sure they will oh no question
with these two I love it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
well I don't know if it gets much more
fun than to have an engagement on the
air no that's pretty that's as good as
it gets right there Dave fun times yeah
fun times Thomas is with us in Arlington
Texas Hey Thomas welcome to the Ramsey
Show
Mr Ramsey it's an honor to be on here
and I will be praying for Andrew and
Colleen thank you sir that's a good
thing I love it how can we help
okay so no debt other than my house or
our house I should say I'm very happily
married
um
credit card everything's gone student
loans gone everything no debt other than
that okay so I wanted to go over my
and please like make adjustments for me
because you have way more money than I
do and I would like to be like you for
my family okay
okay so my three to five year plan is
uh sell the house we owe 129 000 on it
it's a it's over a five hundred thousand
dollar house
um
move into a house to where we owe no
debt and then use the money that I was
gonna be paying in on the mortgage for
that house to give it to a Smart
investor for 15 years and become the
first millionaire in my family
okay mathematically that will work
um
let's let's explore other options uh you
said you're married uh the house is
worth five hundred thousand dollars
um what's your household income
000. okay if we keep the house
you're on baby steps four five six it
sounds like you're investing in the
state and trying to get the house paid
off making 75 000 and doing those other
things uh you owe a hundred and twenty
nine thousand if you
found 25
000 a year you'd be debt free house and
everything in five years
uh if you found less than that it'd take
six or seven years
and oh by then the house is going to be
worth a lot more even
um does your wife like the house
loves it but my life is she told me I
trust you wherever you lead us
that's sweet so I I'm getting being I'm
getting advice from people much smarter
than me before I make a decision how old
are you
and uh wait how old am I 34. that's all
I feel like you're in a little bit of a
rush
to make this happen am I wrong
do you feel rushed are you just trying
to figure out the smartest way to do it
yeah I just wanna you that's why I said
three to five year plan yeah if I said
three to five seconds yeah like right
now but this is later on this is later
on down the road now what do you do for
a living
I am a welder okay all right yes
[Music]
what we normally teach is that we don't
sell the house to move forward unless we
don't like the house or it's a pinch
it's neither here
um so I I am going to say it is just as
good an investment into your family your
marriage and other things to keep this
and systematically everybody if we're
going to keep it we want to be
intentional about how quickly we can pay
it off so let's lay that out and lay out
a five-year plan a seven year plan
whatever it is and just take you know
130 000 bucks 129 000 and divide it into
that right and say I'm going to throw
extra at it and so if we're going to
stay the price I'm going to pay is I'm
going to work overtime this many months
a year
um three months a year and that'll
that'll enable us to pay X on this
because the good news about being a
welder is you can make serious Bank in
OT or doing some side gigs either one
some side hustles I'm probably staying
in the house and paying it off gradually
um I think you're going to end up in
fairly close to the same place if you do
that
that's my guess
that sounds about right I I the two
arguments that are playing in my head is
the only reason on my side of this that
I would not do that that I would sell
the house take the money and buy
something less expensive is if he wasn't
if it wasn't worth it to him to work
more hours and kind of go into that
sacrifice to win mentality if he's
saying you know what like I like my job
I like my flow I like my Pace I don't
want to do that intensity in order to
get this house paid neither one is a
battle yeah neither one is about selling
it and moving it into a 400 000 paid
four house is not a bad answer okay
keeping it and systematically paying it
off in the next five to seven years with
plus or minus some sacrifices to do that
is not a bad answer yeah both of those
are going to land you
15 years from now in a fairly similar
place right there's not a huge
difference in these two you're just
going to be if you keep the house you're
going to be heavier in real estate than
you are in your mutual funds if you go
the other way you're going to be heavier
in mutual funds than you're in real
estate that's true that's the it's the
balance of which way you want to be
there
um
and I appreciate your wife uh saying
I'll go along with whatever I trust you
that's very sweet that's a good
indicator that you're a good man true
that um and uh but I have also learned
over 40 years of marriage that some of
the best investments I make are into our
lives that's true into our marriage into
uh you know this is a trip she really
wants to do this is a she wouldn't she
doesn't like cars but this is a car she
she really likes okay I buy I buy her
I'm the kid with a Tonka truck buying
his mama Tonka truck I buy her cars that
I want and so she has knows
happy wife happy life thing you know and
it's not not that she's a princess or
that his wife's a princess at all that's
not the point but the point is there is
a value to all the hard work that we do
to get a quality of life out of that
absolutely yeah good stuff good question
Dan is in Denver hi Dan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
better than we deserve what's up
hey I just recently changed jobs
um I recently I mean in May of last year
um
uh we have no debt other than our house
um we do maintain
a three thousand dollar balance on a
credit card only because we're told that
showing the activity of paying something
off helps improve our credit score which
we don't really need but we just do it
just uh
because that's what we're told okay when
I change jobs
um my 401k I stopped contributing uh
because the new employer was not
associated with uh
the company that I was using with the
new with the new company I have
um I do have a 401k and I do have my 15
going in there in there
contributing to that but they don't
match
my question is on the on on the first
older 401K I have about 245 in there
what do I do with that to to get to earn
interest or to make it grow
um or or do something I I feel like I'm
just
sitting here yeah just click on
smartvestor at ramseysolutions.com and
find one of the Brokers that we endorse
that we have vetted that you're
comfortable working with they'll have
the heart of a teacher and here's the
phrase you need to remember a direct
transfer rollover to an IRA that means
that the money is not coming to you it's
coming straight into the mutual fund
into the IRA there's zero taxes on that
if you have a traditional IRA now you
direct transfer it to a traditional if
you have a Roth IRA or Roth 401k now you
direct transfer to a Roth whatever it is
but they're going to move the money from
the 401K directly into the mutual funds
that you purchase and they'll send them
the send the notice for you over to your
old company and cause that to happen if
you lay your pause on it they have to
withhold 20 percent you don't want them
to do that so you the direct transfer is
the key thing and I always take my 401K
with me yeah I would because a lot of
this this that's on the amount of 401ks
that people
forget about and they're just left
floating in the air is crazy yeah I'm
probably not gonna forget about 245 not
that much but you would be surprised
Dave just the same you're right I
wouldn't be surprised it's crazy and the
other thing is you'll get a better rate
of return if you watch your own
Investments and manage them actively
with your smartvester pro then you will
just leaving it behind it as a memory
back there and that's a lot of money to
just be floating out there in la la land
so to speak so absolutely yeah and cut
up that credit card please yes that's a
bunch of crap you're chasing dollars in
get rid of the worshiping at the altar
the FICO is a bad idea this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
you can find all of our shows with the
Ramsay Network app on your smartphone
it's the only place to listen to the
entire back catalog of episodes download
the Ramsay Network app in your favorite
app store today
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us my co-host
today Jade warshaw Ramsey personality
we're here to answer your questions
about your life and your money triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Colby's with us in Las Vegas hi Colby
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how you doing great man what's up
so I'm just recently graduated high
school got a job as a car salesman I
still have yet to buy a car I'm just
using like a hand-me-down my dad gave my
brother gave it to me then I'm gonna
give it to my sister in about eight
months or so
so my dealership if they'll pay if you
buy a car they'll pay your payment
they'll pay 500 of your payment every
month for 36 months and I was planning
on buying a car cash but I was just
curious if I should you know take
advantage of this and just put as much
money down to get 500 bucks a month and
obviously have the money to pay it off
if I need to
but you know free money is that
something I should do or shouldn't do
have you asked them if they will give
you
money towards you buying a car and cash
from them
no it's just they just do a payment that
the owner of the dealership I work at
will give you the money no
I'm not gonna do it
yeah I was playing I have about a forty
thousand dollars saved and I was just
planning on just buying some cash and if
not or doing the payments where did you
get forty thousand dollars while you
were in high school
jobs every year since I've started
working I've pretty much tripled how
much I've made at every job what was
your matter what was your best job
what's the thing you made the most money
at
when I'm making about
seven to ten Grand a month give or take
okay so you're already selling some cars
yes yeah I've got I've got a smiling
face I guess and you graduated from high
school last spring
yeah about uh yeah good job so you're 18
years old
yes sir wow very impressive and I was
just planning on buying something that's
probably a truck something nice not not
to and they give you
crazy money off on trucks yeah
um
well
here's the the way I ask these we answer
questions like this is which of the
answers puts me in the best position
giving given Anything Can Happen 10
years from today
okay 10 minutes from today if that's all
you're thinking about you do this deal
right because it's really juicy
it really sounds appealing 10 years from
today
um you work there another year and a
half
and something bad happens to the
dealership or whatever and they just
decide they don't want you anymore and
you get to leave for whatever reason
you've still got 18 months of 500
payments left
because they're not going to pay these
payments if you're gone
yes
so I mean I was just planning on just
saving the rest of the money I have and
having them pay the payment and I could
pay it off cash or something get fired
or quit or find something better
yeah and I assume this needs to be a new
car for this deal right
yeah so you're going to lose your butt
they go down they go down in value Like
a Rock if they were really if they
really wanted to help you no they're
this they're trying to get him to be a
part of the what he said part of what
you're selling yeah so you can you can
talk about you just bought the same
thing the same way and that's the reason
for this it's not necessarily to be a
blessing
um the uh so now I I I if you were uh
like one of my nephews or something I
would tell you not to do this I I I I
understand the appeal of it it sounds
kind of fun it sounds kind of cool it
sounds like there's nothing could go
wrong but number one we don't tell
people to buy new cars unless they have
a million dollar net worth because you
can't absorb the loss
you're going to lose your butt you buy a
40 000 truck whatever it's going to be
worth half of that and 36 to 48 months
and so you need to be buying things that
are going up in value not down in value
this is your largest asset that's going
the wrong direction and that that's the
problem with the scenario so you're
being tempted into something that you're
not financially really ready for uh even
though you have the money to pay cash
for it but you're you don't have the net
worth to absorb the loss of value that
you're going to experience here and so
we tell folks not to buy a new car
unless you got a million dollar net
worth so that that would be the answer
to the question and in this case you're
signing up for car payments I know they
said they're going to pay them but not
if you're not there or they're not there
that's true and so you're you're on the
hook and you're going to find out when
things go sideways the way this stuff
looks it's not good so no I I don't want
that
um
you know at all if you were going to
write a check and pay cash for the car
today I would tell you not to do it too
by the way same thing
you know and and I'm glad you're making
money selling cars I'm glad you're
helpful to people and there's nothing
wrong with that I appreciate that I
appreciate a good salesman I really
appreciate that you're doing this and 18
years old you're really pulling this off
well done that's good just go make
yourself a big old pile of money man and
don't get sucked into owning a new car
and that's that's exactly what I would
do in this scenario now if you want to
get rid of the little dinky car and get
you a ten thousand dollar truck and you
pay cash for it out of your money
that'll be fine that'll be fine but um
if uh if the only way you get to work
there is you have to be a customer
that's a problem that's a problem so I
agree open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Alex is in
Baltimore hey Alex how are you
how you doing Dave good good how can we
help
I I'm my wife and I currently uh were
taking your piece uh University at our
church uh currently on step two but we
are kind of looking ahead at the college
plans for our two children uh we had a
small savings account for each of them
we moved our daughters over to a 529
um
uh but our son uh he's six years old and
he's autistic and we're not quite
certain about his uh College future so
we're very hesitant to set up a 529 for
him and just kind of wanted to get your
inputs about whether you know if there's
any other options or should we just kind
of take the chance and go with the 529
for him uh I I wouldn't try for his
future yeah I wouldn't I would just I
would just have a mutual fund to send
your name and your wife's name and you
just put a little label on that file
with his name on it but he doesn't own
any of it he has no rights to it it's
just your money you're saving for him
the same amount you're saving for your
daughter for college but we're going to
help him with uh maybe he's able to
maybe he's high function he's able to go
to school a higher education or maybe
he's going to go trade school or maybe
he's going to study code or whatever I
don't know but you'll have some money
nick uh earmarked for him but that has
no constraints on it the only
disadvantage to that is is you've got to
pay taxes on it as it grows but whoopty
Dumpty you need the control of it you
don't need it dropping into his name
um and he has legal rights to it and
then uh you know make some bad decisions
that's not good for him or you
mutual fund and that's yours yep but you
just kind of write his name on the
outside of the file in your file drawer
so you know that that's that's a little
little Henry or whatever his name is
right that's the deal right and he's got
access to it whenever he needs it
there's no penalty for that no none
whatsoever but you'll pay taxes on it as
it grows right no this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
have you ever met a natural born leader
well let me answer that for you no you
haven't I've been to the hospital it's a
boy it's a girl they never come out and
say it's a leader
leaders are built they're not born the
great thing about it is you get to
decide what kind of leader you're going
to be you can be loud and crazy like me
you can be quiet and very detailed and
still be a leader there's lots of ways
to be a leader if you want to take your
leadership to the next level join us and
the thousands of Business Leaders who
have already grabbed their seats for
entree Leadership Summit this May 30th
through June 2nd in Nashville
you're going to learn from some of the
best Minds in leadership like Malcolm
Gladwell
Dr Jordan Peterson will be speaking
Monique shohan will be speaking Willie
Robertson of Duck Dynasty will be
speaking I'll be speaking Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney will be speaking it is
quite a lineup for the week
and we'd love to have you right my
friend Brian buffini is joining us too
yeah you don't want to miss this it's
going to be incredible entree Leadership
Summit total game changer for leaders
and business owners
ramseysolutions.com Summit
we've got just a couple tickets left it
is basically sold out but if you want to
come in that's it entree Leadership
Summit
at on at uh well the way to get your
tickets let me try one more time
ramseysolutions.com summit that will get
you there so Jade I just got this uh at
the break from our real estate team uh
uh inventory on real estate is
increasing year over year at a higher
rate and is still well below historical
averages we still have a housing
shortage even though number of homes for
sales increase 67 percent over last year
the total number of unsold homes
including homes that are under contract
has increased only by 13 interesting
newly listed homes are well below
historical averages
and we are at 15.9 percent fewer homes
being listed compared to last year the
median price of homes for sale
has increased
7.8 percent in February
lower than January's growth rate okay
but we're up housing prices nationally
up January up February much like we
predicted yes when we did the real
estate live stream last fall we told you
there was going to continue to be a
shortage we're going to see a seven to
an eight percent increase in prices in
2023 and we are currently tracking for
7.8 percent
and uh homes are spending 67 days on the
market which is 23 days longer than last
year but still shorter than most times
in history when they run 90 to 120 days
I mean if you want to compare the market
to Crazy Town which was 2020 and 2021
were things I remember when we sold our
house I mean the timing to be a Ramsey
personality move from Miami was
incredible well our real estate agent
was apologizing because we only had
eight offers yeah
you know it's like sorry we didn't get
you know that day the day of the open
house sorry you know we only had four
today and only only four the next day so
translation if you're not putting your
home on the market because you think the
market is slow you're statistically
speaking wrong
if you're not putting your home on the
market because you're thinking the real
estate market is down
statistically speaking on a national
average you're wrong
great time to sell a house from the
house when the when there's a housing
shortage
we have more houses for sale than we did
this time last year but again we're
still coming out the back of Crazy Town
last year right so we we're we're
returning to a more normal level of
inventory with still more buyers than
sellers
still
even with high interest rates but the
interest rates do not drive the market
as much as Supply demand drives the
market
meaning meaning the prices are going to
go up as long as there are more buyers
than sellers there's a housing shortage
you're always going to see price that's
why we've got an 8 7.8 price increase or
schedule I mean that's what we're
tracking for annually now it's not 32
percent during Crazy Town right
and that's what people can't get used to
so
um
Megan Kelly's podcast the other day
she's been a friend a long time and she
said so what do you mean I said well
Megan it's like if you're driving your
car like 90 or 100 miles an hour and
then you slow down to 45 it feels like
you're you're like you're crawling yeah
and she goes I've never had that feeling
hahaha
that's funny she I think she obeys the
law but yeah there you go so um I just
feel like we have short memories
as as as American people our memory is
is We compare We compare
not to historical distance you're right
but into what the last thing I felt last
like Friday that's what it is we're
basing it on pure emotion and are we you
know what are we hearing on the uh God
awful news channel right yeah that's
what it is they're just telling us our
world's coming to an end world's coming
to an end if you didn't know the world's
coming to an end and you're going to die
of a tornado too by the way I just think
that's a problem though when we we're
listening to a talking head tell us
something contrary to what our own
experience is telling us what our own
memory should tell us yeah and the
reason I put these this data out when I
got the email at the break I thought you
know John Delaney talks about facts yep
are your friends yep when you have fear
or you're worried or whatever facts are
your friends in the middle of an
emergency situation stop and analyze the
facts facts are your friends what's the
real situation here and what you're most
of the time run into when you do that is
it calms you down and you say I'm not
going to sweat the small stuff and most
everything that I'm worried about is
small stuff in the scope of your life
yeah
in the scope of your life yeah that's it
so there you go Kelly is with us in
Chicago hi Kelly welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave hi Jade thanks for taking my
call no problem how are you doing
I'm good how are you guys good
how can we help so I'm just calling this
just going with the question um so I
purchased the house one year ago we
closed on April 29th last year
um purchase this home for 320 000. I
currently still owe 298.5
um and I'm just calling so I originally
purchased this home um with the intent
of living here with somebody that
relationship is no longer there and he
never even ended up moving in with me so
I make these payments by myself and I'm
feeling
um so I work full time and then I also
have a part-time job and I'm feeling
like maybe I'm a little house poor and
was considering spelling
um but I'm wondering if selling this
soon would be a mistake
how much are your monthly payments
1800 for just the mortgage and how much
is your monthly income
um it varies I pick up a lot of overtime
I make forty two dollars an hour full
time as a nurse and then part-time I
work like 20 hours how much money are
you bringing in a month
um about 4 500. yeah you're starving to
death mm-hmm
so it's not fun no
I was like I think it might be time as
long as you guys think it's wise I think
that's probably what
up why wouldn't you
because you're feeling that you're
feeling the pinch already what's what
and it's tied to a negative relationship
as well so what's what would keep you
staying in it do you foresee your income
going up drastically is there something
that we don't know about that's
no well you contemplated renting out a
room because it is a three bedroom home
and just me living here so I've
contemplated renting out a room
um but I'm thinking with all of the fees
and you never know what's going to go
wrong with the house I just think that I
would be client-side and I'd be better
off selling and like stockpiling money
and paying cash for
one you know in the next year or two I
like that in the short term yeah in the
short term I would be moving back home
which I don't love that idea but um it's
temporary so
I would get out of the home I'm not
really sure why you've got to move back
in with your parents if you take so if
you I mean you're making an income you
can't rent in your area
I could I just thought that would be the
cheapest easiest way I mean I would pay
rent there too so I got to be the same
thing yeah I think I'd give me an
inexpensive rental and sell it and the
moral of the story ladies and gentlemen
is never buy a home with someone you're
not married to
well it's a committed you're not married
if you were married it'd be committed
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today Chad and
Tracy are with us on the debt free stage
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
headquarters hey guys how are you great
how are you fantastic welcome welcome
where do you all live
Columbus Ohio cool welcome to Nashville
and how much data have you paid off
we paid off two hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars all right how long did
this take
just around eight years okay way to go
and your range of income during that
time we started off making about a
hundred and nineteen
uh dipped down to maybe 109.
and now we're about 149. cool what do
y'all do for a living
I am a recruiter at a manufacturing
company and I'm in procurement in the
automotive industry huh very good okay
000 eight years what kind of debt was
this
a variety of student loans credit cards
um line of credit HELOC you pay off the
whole house or just the HELOC so you get
free house and everything yeah
everything I love it look at it weird
people good job y'all cool so what's the
house worth
the house I think I just saw the other
day is worth about 430. all right I love
it good for you guys when you guys said
you paid off the house somebody to the
side over there got really really
excited
so these two uh Jeff and Julie Reyes are
our mentors because they taught us our
debt or I'm sorry our class that we took
first FPU yes yep oh wow we are they're
just awesome so they really motivated us
to take the class to get debt free so we
owe a lot of our
um story to them that's exciting where
did you take the class we took the class
at our church which is discover
Christian Church in about 2014 I believe
it was yes excellent and Dave if I could
if I could if I may for a second tell
you a little bit of History
um I started to get into real estate
investment
um uh not not a little bit of parallels
to you in 2008 2009 everything crashed
we couldn't find rentals and I had to
file bankruptcy in 2012. and uh so that
was quite a bit of straw in fact I filed
the paperwork on my birthday which is
wow pretty exciting yeah
um but uh but you know I I asked Tracy
if we could take Financial Peace I've
been wanting to take it wanting to take
it and finally in January uh the Reyes
is over here we're teaching class and
and that started our journey oh wow very
cool very cool so really from the bottom
all the way up then yeah for sure yeah
that's a long Trek it is congratulations
y'all and we we have two boys that uh
have some debilitating diseases and uh
that's our motivation yeah yeah get your
where you can take care of them instead
of paying some Bank amen exactly amen
amen and amen well done y'all how's it
feel to be completely free feels amazing
yeah we haven't been able to walk on the
grass yet because it's been winter time
but uh but we're excited to do that and
you know along this journey it's been
fantastic from a standpoint of us being
debt free uh to uh now having uh wills
and Special Needs Trust set up for our
boys absolutely
um and knowing that if something happens
to me or something happens to Tracy
that we're going to be okay yeah and
they're going to be okay they're gonna
be okay everybody's taken care of in in
the family tree that we started amen and
uh just very blessed in them so thankful
uh that God uses the Ramsey solution uh
to reach People Like Us uh that we are
able to now take care of our family tree
and and subsequently we've taught about
five or six FPU classes wow okay we've
we've taught smart money smart kids wow
thank you very good we're just we're all
in doing it all excellent well thank you
you're paying it forward for sure all
right thank you thank you thank you so
when you're teaching a class or when you
were going through
what do you think most often is the
light bulb moment where someone says
all right I'm doing it
you see the you see the light come on
over their head right you can you see
their faces change when do you think
that happens most what do you think
drives that I think when they start to
pay off you know the smallest at first
they can cross that off the list so the
Snowball Effect I think that really
they're like wow I got this paid off I'm
gonna move to the next one I think
that's very motivating and I think
that's where I see a lot of the students
in our class
um get really excited and uh for me you
know what I've heard recently or a lot
of when people have had that I've had at
moment when they've when they reached
that I've had it moment when when they
when preparedness an opportunity meet
and
um and a lot of our folks heed that and
carry on their Journey
so what was your I've had it moment
I think we got so tired of like we would
use the whole what was that like debt
consolidation loan and now I look back
and I laugh going why would you think
that would work and you know after after
you've like you know took the class
taught the class it's just not gonna
work so it's you have to you don't just
move the debt you have to get rid of it
you have to think differently you have
to change your whole life to think about
Dave's principles and use them and I
look a lot like Fitness to me that's the
same thing like when you go on a diet
you can't just lose the weight and it
stays there you have to think
differently so it's similar with money
to stay out of debt so for me
um I think we were just so tired of oh
my gosh we have this to pay and we would
fight about money and it's like what can
we do so when Chad said let's take the
class at church I'm like you know it
can't hurt let's try it so we did and
here we are and we did treat the HELOC
like a pet we kept it for a long period
of time it's not a good idea so if
anyone's listening just not a good idea
what you're saying is behavior matters
it's not just about mathematics on paper
right change your habits yes if you
can't if you don't as Dave says if you
don't have the money don't buy it put
those words into action for sure way to
go you guys we're so proud of you thank
you thank you you look like a power
couple man I mean you're pretty
incredible well done very well done and
thanks for teaching the classification
University to others you've had a huge
impact on other people's lives I'm sure
like your mentors did on yours right so
very very well but I do have to say if
it's okay my youngest son who's 15. Noah
we actually had our all of our debt paid
except for our house probably in 2016
Chad is that right
um so we were excited to be debt free in
2016 without the house you know being
paid off and Noah would remind us mom
we're not debt free until the house is
paid
One in Every Family yeah I like it I
know dude I like it yeah he's very good
he picked up on the podcast for sure
very hard I love that I we got to live
and give bundle for you uh that includes
The Total Money Makeover book to give to
somebody baby steps millionaires book to
give to somebody you're probably right
there or on your way to that as well and
another uh Financial Peace University
membership you'll be able to give that
away because it's the world you're all
are living in now way to go you guys
very cool well let's get the gentleman
to uh they want to come around front of
the stage there and uh work this out or
up on even he's going to come up on
that'll work too works for me good stuff
so their names and ages
this is Noah on the left with the orange
shirt uh he is 15.
and this is Jacob on the right he's 23.
all right very cool all right guys here
we go I love it 218
000 paid off in eight years making 119
to 149. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go you guys that's how it's done
I love it there's a domino effect there
and I you see it with the first
coordinators they taught them and then
they've coordinated over five six
classes and it's just a domino effect of
financial peace yeah it's very cool and
your classic your started up has got you
had a limit of a thousand people we had
to cut it off I had to cut it off you
got it full it's full we had to cut it
off we've met twice so for anybody
asking because I've had several people
come in and say can I still sign up for
the class we had to cut it off but don't
worry we'll do it again yeah we're gonna
do it again I bet you you gotta you know
and you know I don't know y'all mate
y'all may find out Jade is tough
I had to get on somebody about their
credit cards the other night so you know
don't don't don't be messing around in
that class you got a tough coordinator
the real deal right there oh yeah man
that's such a great story way to go you
guys you're amazing good stuff this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Luke 11 8 I
tell you even though he will not get up
and give him anything because he is your
his friend yet because of his
persistence he will get up and give him
as much as he needs
what version is that okay
that's not even recognizable okay Andrew
says I believe persistence is a major
key to success in any great endeavor
I want to remind folks to persist in
whatever they're tackling at the moment
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money rashonda is with us in
Boston Hi rashonda how are you
I'm great thank you good how can we help
so I am in a little bit of I have a
current stressor right now concerning
um some past that I I incurred when I
was in my early 20s I'm 27 now and I'm
learning very quickly after my 25th
birthday I am paying dearly in my late
24 mistakes I've made uh financially in
my early 20s my current stressor would
be my car debt my car loan
um it's my second vehicle and
um I got it a year ago from February
from Valentine's Day and I am wondering
if I'm I don't have the limiting options
because I I rolled over negative equity
and right now I'm looking at roughly 31
000 for the payoff on this car it's a
Lexus it's a 2016 Lexus and
um I am wondering I know you say not to
get what you call fleece but
um I'm wondering if just to kind of
cushion and alleviate some of that
stress right now have you looked up what
the car is worth
I did a kbd yeah on what the mileage is
for now and it's roughly 16 650.
uh on a private sale or trade-in
on a trade-in
okay so private shall be 20. and you're
31 000 did you say you leased this
no I initially I finance
your actual payoff is really Thirty one
thousand
correct you're sure of that
correct um the last time I checked
that's why you're interested in the
party my interest is like almost nine
percent
now when you said this was your second
vehicle you're you're meaning that you
had a vehicle and you rolled the equity
the negative equity into this not that
you own two vehicles right
correct okay just double checking that
what's your income
my I just started a new job I'm a
student so uh
it's kind of choppy my I work I earn
like 15 an hour I literally just started
that job but I am I've always had a job
it's just on a normal month how much
money do you bring home
on a normal month I'll say right at 4
000.
um and I assume you have no money
correct okay is this the only debt you
have
or is there more no I have credit card
debt before the loan how much
uh I'll say that is about 13 14 000.
okay
well there's no question mathematically
this is killing you mm-hmm and I feel I
made some very stupid well I feel it me
too I've done it too but I mean I feel
the I feel the math pinch in these
numbers you're this is a real problem
it's a real struggle for you and so what
happened is you had a car that you're
upside down in and then you bought
another car and you're further upside
down and yeah and so we've double dipped
we've got a double hole you know that's
where ten thousand dollars comes from
because you're roughly ten thousand
dollars in the hole
um
you don't have money saved anywhere do
you no she doesn't no we already asked
you yeah no uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I was my my question was I thought I
would have the option I researched it I
don't think that's an option my question
because I mind you I've exhausted as
much as I can in terms of just looking
at my bank and then other I thought well
if I try to lease it
um Coulda or if I don't leave it could I
try to sell it privately put that money
toward the debt and then get my credit
or not the debt my credit card get the
credit score up and then try to get a
consumer loan and put that to work I
said no because that's I think that's
technically illegal because I don't have
the title if I try to sell it well you
won't be able to get the title unless
you pay it off yeah who's got the loan
who holds the loan
uh my bank nfcu have you talked to them
about
do you have a local branch there
no the closest one is about 70 miles
away Newport Rhode Island
I would try to get someone on the phone
there and discuss with them the idea
that you sell the car they release the
title and you sign a note a personal
loan of credit a personal loan for the
difference the ten thousand dollar
difference
um because that's really where they are
today anyway they're not fully
collateralized on this loan they only
have a twenty thousand dollar cars
collateral against a thirty one thousand
dollar loan and by selling it they have
a better chance of getting their money
you follow me okay and so but it's it it
long distance on a phone call with a
bank like that I you know I give you
less than 50 chance you pull it off but
if you can talk them into it that is
your best case scenario your next best
case scenario is uh find a credit union
a local bank just to loan you ten
thousand dollars again very difficult
but uh you've got to cover the ten
thousand dollar hole to get out of this
either with the current bank accepting a
note for that amount or you coming up
with a cash by signing a note somewhere
else but I would rather you be ten
thousand dollars in debt somewhere else
even on a credit card if you could get a
ten thousand dollar credit card yeah I
would rather be that than be thirty
thousand dollars in debt on this car now
of course that leaves you Carlos right
she's got to get something to do that
and so then you've got to work like a
crazy person and scratch together a
thousand two thousand dollars and pay
cash for a little garage sale car
something that's pitiful you need a
pitiful car mm-hmm
that you pay cash for with no payments
pitiful and no payments and then that
breaks the back on this cycle but there
is no lease on it there's no leasing it
that's not going to work because all of
it's going to be rolled into that anyway
yeah the 31 000 is going to be rolled
into that and it's still it doesn't go
away your payment is your payment is
your payment and your lease payment
might actually be higher
and so um
that's easier so yeah but the trick is
uh working your tail end off taking like
8 000 hours of work I mean you just work
until you're about to drop you know go
go work six jobs whatever you've got to
do scratch together some money and or
borrow that some portion of that ten
thousand dollar hole that you're in put
that and then someone comes along and
gives you twenty thousand dollars for
the car you put the ten thousand dollars
from the loan or the work with it that
gets the car paid off and you can give
the title to them but you're going to
have this other loan over to the side
you see what I'm saying
okay but you can't sell the car to
someone unless you can give the bank
Thirty one thousand dollars or they will
agree to let you sign a note for the
difference
okay and release the title The title's
got to be released in the transaction
it's not illegal it's just the buyer
won't do it
okay because the nobody buys a car you
don't get the title
okay it's pretty scary in Massachusetts
they don't play games about life yeah
well they shouldn't they shouldn't I
mean you shouldn't sell a car you can't
get the title I mean so you've got it
but you can get it all set up to where
it's perfectly legal what I'm describing
is perfectly illegal in any state
because if you give them Thirty one
thousand dollars or they agree to let
you sign a note for the difference
doesn't matter they're gonna that you
know they've you've now got a way to
release the title to the buyer and
that's what you have to do that yeah
because once she comes up with the
difference they don't know the
difference I mean she's just giving them
the money for the car so of course
they're going to give her the title so
if you find somebody to loan you 10 and
you put on the market for 20. you know
and you can get Joe to buy it for 20.
Joe gives you 20. you give him a bill of
sale and you know you put the other 10
with it and now you've got a clear title
to handle Joe and that's the process
that you'll use but yeah that's what
you're going to have to scratch and Claw
to get out of this because it's a deep
hole I'm so sorry yeah I've been in that
kind of mess it's no fun
that's a tough hole to get out of but
you can get out of it and you will get
out of it absolutely
good show today gang that puts this hour
of the Ramsay show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]